bridgeport connecticut an industrial
city on the connecticut coast only an
hour north of manhattan
nestled in a quaint neighborhood called
blackrock is cafe tavellini
owners keith and lisa rustivo bought a
successful italian restaurant on a whim
having never worked in the business
before
lisa and i were driving past this
building and there was a four rent sign
on it
we didn't know the restaurant business
i'm a hairdresser by trade in keith own
liquor stores we had no clue
nice to see you nice to see you how are
you honey when the place opened up it
was mopped doing great numbers everybody
was happy is your state cooked all right
we were the newest restaurant around and
we were definitely riding the wave of
success
[Music]
now you walk in here on a saturday night
you think that it's like a [ __ ] old
western movie like the [ __ ] things
are rolling by
[Music]
i don't even want to come here tonight
our business started to turn negative we
start to turn negative with it also this
place is really driving me crazy my
mother and keith do not care the two of
them hate being here
michael hate to bother you do you have
my car keys by chance i try to oversee
um that full operation of the restaurant
[Applause]
[Music]
i don't really know what keith does here
i really don't don't don't tell me um
[Music]
he'll act like he's the boss he says i'm
busy i'm busy i gotta go i gotta go but
what are you so busy with you don't do
anything all day
you sleep till [ __ ] two o'clock you
come here you blow the patio and then
you sit home all day
you lay down here too i wish i had your
[ __ ] life
why are aren't the rest lights out in
the restaurant at 5 5 30 at night
what frustrates me is the lack of
management period you know he'll sit at
home and stare at the surveillance
camera and basically nitpicks why is
everybody sitting down here
if you
have this much money into the place why
aren't you there when the place isn't
working
the numbers are just
ridiculous and i cannot pay bills with
no money
we're probably in debt 350 000
this is what's going to have to happen i
don't want to talk about it anymore our
marriage is at a brink because we fight
constantly fighting and fighting and
fighting is not going to get anyone
anywhere
we need chef ramsay's help because we
are at the end of our ropes
if things don't change i don't know what
is going to happen
if they don't take gordon's advice
the marriage is gonna fail and the
restaurant's gonna fail
[Music]
ramsay is aware that cafe tavellini has
its issues taste of italy
but before he can step in the door to
explore i accorded there is one family
member who can't wait to unload nice to
meet you very cool can i talk to you for
a quick second before we go in no yeah
yeah jump in oh jump in
i wanted to meet up with chef ramsey
because i wanted to tell him every
little bit of dirt
you obviously got something important to
tell me yeah first of all it's a family
business right yeah family run and it's
your mum and dad who owns it my mother
and my stepfather yes mom and stepfather
um are they in there yes he is in there
i just wanted to let you know that the
only reason why he's there today is
because he found out that you were
coming there so he's not hands on no
he'd be in bed right now actually if you
weren't coming there
you are kidding me he's lost
he needs your help
what does mom do
she just basically doesn't want to be
there he blames her for everything for
not being successful it's always her
fault
thanks for the heads up let's just keep
this
between us next take everybody thanks
[Music]
man he's freezing
hi how are you hey mr ramsay how are you
golden police good morning good to see
you first name is uh keith stevo chief
manager owner owner yes hi along with my
wife lisa lisa good to see you
so um husband and wife team yes um any
of the members of the family working in
the restaurant yes they do my son van
gaal okay my daughter jolie so
restaurants open how many days a week
seven days a week and you're here well
i'm here almost every day
i actually don't work during the day i'm
here
[Music]
hello people
and this is this is good
okay you do yeah work here waiter here
how many times uh a week are you here
four to five so you're here six days a
week you're here nights only and you're
here four days a week four
zero zero
[Music]
lisa keith you're gonna have to help me
out here hold on a minute when you're
not here i'm here just i'm just we're
here i'm just a little bit confused
first of all six days a week now is no
days a week
but i'm telling you the truth you just
said i'm not lying
but you're not you're gonna help he
needs to know the
he is truth okay
okay and the more
i get up to speed from all of you the
quicker i can look at the scenario
i just want the truth and nothing but
the truth that just helps me
tenfold okay uh right where should i sit
wherever yeah yep
thank you let's eat yellow
okay
by throwing me out of the bus
i haven't even sat down and the [ __ ]
starts
i told you
since when did vj get through the
head honcho what happened well he's
running the whole show right here
[Music]
wow huge menu
ready or oh yes let's start with
grandma's pamphlet meatballs served over
house salad okay and then the salmon pan
roasted slowly okay and the clams oh the
stuff clams no problem thank you
hi how are you good to see you sorry
rick nice to meet you what'd you do
you're the bartender server bartender um
what's wrong with the questions uh lack
of management
lack of management owners not here very
much
keith what are you gonna do i'm gonna
have to pick some liquor up i'm kind of
a quick one of the keith again please
yeah thank you
where's case you left go get him hurry
up
which surprise
oh he left keith is not here on a
regular basis boy i want to talk skis
mercy do that
i could go two or three days without
seeing keith he doesn't have the concept
of priorities of what needs to be done
to make this restaurant work why don't
you go over there and say he had to go
over on his behalf and say he had to
leave to get some products for the
restaurant he should have did that
earlier
he's fed up with everything when he
comes in and he sees one thing wrong he
could so i'll twist it and he jumps in
the car and he leaves
thank you
lisa
a meatball salad a stuffed clams those
are [ __ ] nothing as fast as you can
michael in a way don't like the success
[Music]
i was a server at cafeteria i recently
moved into the kitchen make sure you get
cheese on there please which was uh
lagging quite a bit
oh jesus meatball salad meatball salad
fresh ground peppers
thank you
grandma's meatballs
look at that
wow
right now that's an insult to
grandmothers
that's a mess
gross
hours of big soggy dirty pool of juice
crap underneath there
thank you
jesus
what do you say about evil he said that
it was it was dreadful that it was
swimming in sauce
ugh that was hairy
what's happening oh did he like he said
that that meatball is
[ __ ] horrible no problem
[Music]
stop smelling this these are horrible i
want to put them in the oven or michael
all right put it with me you're taking
responsibility for that if he says it
all right
[Music]
[Music]
thank you besides it looks like some
dumb shack in my shell
where's the clap
but where's the clay
it's got to be mixed in there no it's
mush but where are the clams
i don't see it either taste that please
i was like a little scared to eat off
his plate because i thought he was going
to stab me with the fork if like i told
him it was good
i just taste bread crumbs does that mean
microwave i mean it tastes like a
stuffing that you just stick in the ass
end of a turkey
i'll take it out of your way
oh my god
he said that there's no clams in this he
said that this tastes like a stuffing
out of a turkey this stuff clams a
garbage anyway
keith he hates our food he said that the
stuffing and the stuffed clams tastes
like it should be from like the ass of a
turkey or something
don't you dare blame me for anything
like that okay can i have that salmon
coming right now
taste
of italy no
certainly not in the kitchens maybe a
taste of the italian sewers
okay here we go um i always get nervous
when the chefs start decorating the
plates with parsley
[Music]
oops
undercooked salmon that's stone cold in
the middle
mush
taste the device for me
[Music]
so you got
insepared
when was that made
i think he made that yesterday oh
[ __ ]
yesterday yeah how much is that 21. 21.
so that's a taste of italian leftovers
for 21.
no jesus want anything else uh a sick
bag maybe
thank you holy [ __ ]
[Music]
did you look at the liquor
why we're about to get rings right now
he said he hates every single thing on
the menu he hates everything that he
hates and everything is totally totally
disgusting
i'm gonna talk to him later
don't let me elbow you um stop can you
give something i'm not lying
you don't know you're here at 4 30. you
don't know what i do watch yourself bro
just keep that in mind
you're basically just making yourself
look like a bigger jackass when you lie
about things so why don't you just come
clean he's obviously here to help you
so let gordon help you you have no clue
what i do okay except when i get here
you're right you're right
before you found out he was coming here
we'll close your restaurant every night
stop don't say shush stop stop sam's
wife
what's going on back there he's here to
help us
jesus somebody call the police
what why am i lying i don't understand
how i'm blind i'm being honest that
you're never [ __ ] at your restaurant
your son not mine ignore them right now
because you're embarrassing me
i'm leaving
yes i am i'm leaving right now
[Music]
during chef ramsay's dismal first meal
at cafe tavellini looks like some dogs
shot in my shell the tension between
owner keith and step son van before you
found out he was coming here who closed
your restaurant every night stop it has
erupted into a battle
keith i'm leaving
and wife and mother lisa is caught in
the crossfire i'm leaving right now shut
up
what's going on
i'm gonna walk out and i'm gonna leave
no you're not leaving don't say another
word then you don't see another word
then what's going on he gets mad because
i'm trying to tell him the truth and
he's making me try to look like an idiot
in front of you
you can't handle it
that's the problem and you know that
okay
yes sir what's going on oh no i just do
a lot of confrontation why are you lying
he's here to help us he's not here
because the owners run everything
perfectly and this is why he's here and
this is what needs to change and i can't
take it
hey
don't get upset
[Music]
what's the matter
it's just it's just it's just the same
stuff that just comes through it goes on
this business has affected my marriage
totally has affected my family i'm
totally like beside myself you okay i'm
sorry about that ah don't apologize to
me what about an iori that's your lady
and i thought up until now the food was
the biggest problem let me tell you the
menu was a [ __ ] disgrace
hideous but i i definitely apologize for
that okay i need uh i need a break i'll
be back later
[Music]
surprised he's even gonna stay here and
even deal with us because we're all
crazy
with a restaurant and a marriage clearly
on the line please let's have a quick
catch up
yeah just you know yeah chef ramsay
knows he needs to dive in quickly and
gather as much information about the
financials of cafe tavellini help me to
get up to speed with
where we are in business the money is
not coming in i mean the numbers are
disgusting we had a night a couple of
weeks ago
it was dollars in the till
forty dollars wow our house was
foreclosed down
because of the business yep
so we've just been declining and just
failing we can't even take a salary we
could keith walks around seriously
that's why he's so stressed out he
doesn't even have a dollar in his pocket
and as soon as he gets here he'll see
one thing that's aggravates him and then
that's when it starts and this is
because the cash was dried up
how did you get through the day i mean
christian might have you know i'm so
depressed some days i just want to hand
them divorce papers because i can't take
it
if the restaurant closes
i can't see our marriage continuing
you know it's just it just makes it so
difficult
i mean i hope you can help us but is it
too overwhelming
[Music]
let me have a look
i need to see everything in action
tonight okay
okay
[Music]
after a day filled with arguments
tears
and accusations that you're never
[ __ ] at your restaurant
chef ramsay is back to observe a dinner
service the kitchen's small it's a box
you cook 70
odd items on the menu from this
yeah did you ever get stuck in the
corner
no i'm serious i know it's
ridiculous
hi how are you news of chef ramsay's
appearance in connecticut results in a
full restaurant right this way okay guys
and while customers look to satisfy
their appetite lobster ravioli sure
they aren't the only ones
can you order me at dinner yeah i can't
do that right now i need a minute
okay
when you get a minute can you order me a
um no don't talk to me right now
[Music]
that's not the way it works i'm putting
my orders in making sure the customer's
happy now she wants to eat i can't i
can't eat now whoa who wants to take he
wants me to wear dinner lisa just
doesn't get it
well owner lisa has to wait to place her
order i am starving customers in the
dining room
oh my goodness are quickly receiving
their food
maybe a little too quickly and chef
ramsay wants to know why
do you just did you did you just pull it
out of the fridge yeah chef what is that
it's chicken
and why are you cooking them in advance
there's a space it's space for time just
touch that as hard as it were it's
[ __ ] how many ports you got in there
cook ahead show me the trade pj please
that's driving the nevada desert
these look like they were cooked
[Music]
i mean they're yesterday solid
huh
[Music]
i mean i wouldn't hang that on a
christmas tree that chicken it's already
cooked it's gonna get cooked again who
the [ __ ] would want to eat this and he's
absolutely right lisa okay
so i'm trying to go up to speed with the
chefs just feel that there
[Music]
solid chicken for the chicken parm they
don't make it to order
why not
we've always done it that way we really
didn't know it's a problem that's just
that's insane this sucks
despite a fast start how's your meal we
haven't had any yet we're waiting and
it's very long the disorganized kitchen
is now delivering food at a snail's pace
i'm waiting on a cheese ravioli it's
getting hot just give it a second bro
come on dude be right there bro
i'm waiting on 13 and 11. i've never
seen
such a dysfunctional kitchen in all my
[ __ ] life
chris squashed down the corner the
chicken reheated all these plates have
got chips on them what's all those
tickets on the floor it's just madness
my absolute madness where's lisa where's
keith
people haven't gotten their meals in
over 45 minutes the kitchen is just a
whole mess and my mother and keith were
nowhere to be found
is mommy and keith somewhere
they sit in the car for no reason keith
and my mother are sitting out in the
driveway on a crazy crazy night i'm
starving we can't handle this we need
help well you know what maybe they
should come and worry about the problems
that are really happening right now yeah
like how well the kitchen's a disaster
chicken bomb pick it up my mother
ordered this or she's gonna stay in the
car and eat it
is this normal when we get busy i'm
embarrassed now
[Music]
why was this ordered under your name oh
it's mine you're gonna eat it out here
what am i eating with my fingers yeah
that's what they that's what you want
here give me your support
stuffed pork chop primavera white with
penny while the two owners died in the
car where's my bus girl i got a part
fally here's your chicken and sausage i
have 21 and 22. michael does his best to
rally the staff and complete dinner
service
[Music]
okay i'm gonna get straight to the point
you two
you've been abusing your
restaurant van gets angry
michael gets frustrated
ricky gets upset
the owners i didn't see you get upset i
saw you walk outside with a coat and you
were attacking the car it's a joke
keith help me
i uh
my passion is a little uh
you know
down
if you got behind this bar and you got
on the floor and you did something to
show you care people see that
customers aren't going to care about
your business if you don't give a [ __ ]
about it and the two of you said it on a
million occasions walk into place i
don't even give a [ __ ] about this place
anymore i hope it [ __ ] burns well you
know what that's what it's doing burning
right to the [ __ ] ground
[Music]
while lisa's daughter jolie eloquently
sums up a miserable evening customers
aren't gonna care about your business if
you don't give a [ __ ] about it and a
frustrating performance by her parents
why was this ordered under your name oh
it's mine you're gonna eat it out here
jeff ramsey realizes he has to do
something drastic so the following day
oh my god look at the restaurant he
gives keith and lisa a dose of shock
therapy
what the what is that
[Music]
out of business clothes plastered
against the whole side of the building
and uh i just can't believe it
what does this mean
we can't even get in
what's going on well i wish i could say
good morning because it's not a good
morning
don't bother crossing the line
you're shut down
you're out of business
keith
it's [ __ ] up i mean i i just it's not
what i wanted
it's too much money invested please
this is not good
i wrote you a letter last night can you
read it
dear gordon
i want you to know that you have touched
home with your perception of keith and i
we are guilty of negligence and
irresponsibility on our part
keith and i have let our staff and
customers down due to a lack of our
participation at the restaurant
keith and i were oblivious to so much
before you spoke to us tonight
we were in denial
we're in denial of all of our faults
our plea to you is not to give up hope
on us
keith and i are willing to make drastic
changes in our lives to save our
restaurant
unfortunately we need the guidance and
to be able to turn this place around for
the best
we have our full commitment from keith
and i that we will work as hard as we
can
to make the changes
i want to thank you from the bottom of
my heart for coming to cafe tavellini
and opening up our eyes
[Music]
this is exactly what i needed to hear
i'm not giving up
this is a wake-up call
you're not closed today but this will be
the result if we don't start now and i
mean now
today we start the comeback
and i need both you to be committed okay
i hear you hear you loud clear
let's get inside
[Music]
owners keith and lisa have convinced
chef ramsay that they are now committed
to the restaurant but chef ramsay is not
the only one that needs convincing
keith and lisa address your team
i just wanted to apologize to the staff
for our negligence giving up on
something which i know is everybody's
livelihood here
i love you guys for being here you've
been with us since day one and if you
really didn't care about us you would
never be here
and i really appreciate it and i do want
to get it to a better point
[Music]
if it wasn't for you guys i don't know
what i would do
you guys really are a great staff and
you really have stuck by us
it's our fault because we just just gave
up because we just couldn't handle the
pressure
[Music]
i realized that i need to be more
hands-on it's going to be a personal
goal of mine to you know work at it i
think keith and my mom are definitely
sincere about what's going on i think
it's definitely an eye-opener for them
everything here in the last five years
has been negative so it was definitely a
breath of fresh air
[Music]
for tonight's dinner service chef ramsay
institutes some major changes we have to
stand out from the competition so we
need to do something that no one else is
doing a family-style menu that features
a tuscan bean soup porchetta with
roasted vegetables and olive oil cake
a menu family style has to show
convenience for the kitchen and the
customers will help themselves
service becomes a lot more efficient and
the kitchen gets out the weeds it is a
very small kitchen family style dining
should help their kitchen run more
smoothly and for the first time the two
owners are hands on and working tonight
owners keith and lisa will have active
roles in their restaurant lisa you're
gonna roll those things up tonight
you're serving
there you go but i haven't been a server
before you're gonna be a server tonight
okay
i want you physically on the floor what
are you good at doing i could make up a
cocktail and i could promote it good i
like that i've never surfed before i
needed to be a little bit scary i didn't
see that coming at all okay let's go
we're opening eight minutes yeah let's
go
there's definitely a new energy in the
restaurant tonight when i order it in a
computer am i hitting two that means the
party or two go over there and i'll show
you and both owners are optimistic what
are you gonna do
uh pomegranate bellini's yeah it sounds
amazing and so is chef ramsay a
pomegranate bellini
i don't know what's in store for tonight
but i know that i'm definitely gonna hit
up the [ __ ] church down the road and
pray before when i go on the floor
tonight
we're offering a family style tonight so
you guys make a decision and i'll be
back in a few
family style
pomegranate bellini would be our special
dinner drink we should get a round of
those
keith has wanted an active role i just
don't think he actually knew that he was
able to do that this is your creation
this is delicious oh good thank you
eat in the flesh i want eight bellini's
okay good
lisa service
yeah
that looks good would you like another
beer
okay okay bro you're doing such a nice
job lisa being a server it actually felt
good
it smells delicious would you like some
fresh um pepper yeah too your first tan
comments about the food it was exciting
it's so nice to see you being involved
it brings you closer
not just to the customers but to your
team
with the owners and staff hard at work
then table 12. here we go
the service is off to a good start
and the diners love the family style
specials these are awesome but the
customers who order from the regular
menu it's taking forever for having a
completely different experience
did you go family style or did you go
off the menu
family style it seems to be coming out a
little bit faster
[Music]
everybody okay your tables are good
they're not all right
i'm starving this one
michael i'm waiting on 32. can i get
table 21 please they've been waiting for
an hour and a half i'm waiting i'm
waiting right now i'm waiting on a
flight out of here
let's complete a [ __ ] table let me
get our [ __ ] together love all those
tickets oh my god almighty this is crazy
everybody come here come here come here
you guys have to seriously get a [ __ ]
grip
and lisa
yeah you can't run a restaurant with a
70 item menu from this kitchen
[Music]
this is insane
if i was the owner i would want to look
after every single person that hasn't
gotten their meal say hey can i get you
guys a dessert can i get you guys a
drink i'm sorry my mother was just
walking around aimlessly and keith
wasn't doing anything they just really
showed no ownership skills tonight
[Music]
you
sorry guys i know it's hectic but i'm
just gonna be right back in
nightmare i didn't know what to do i was
just too embarrassed to even go up to
any tables to apologize i just kind of
zoned out and couldn't do anything
[Music]
where's keith he's not out at a liquor
store for a hot dog where is he while
keith and lisa failed to tackle
tonight's problems ricky needs a
meatball platform i need it now a leader
has emerged in the kitchen you got it
michael steps up and does his best to
push orders out
spaghetti meatballs chris thank you we
got a meatball ticket after that what's
next come on here's stuffed pork chop a
chicken parm mediterranean meatball
platter so porchetta meatballs broccoli
rabe and as a result the remaining a la
carte orders start hitting the tables
this is your final table here fettuccine
you got a toronto
[Music]
thanks for coming come back and see us
[Music]
okay
first let me start with the
positive the family style menu came out
quicker and it's satisfied to customers
considering the size of the kitchen it's
clearly the direction this restaurant
needs to start moving towards but we
have a long way to go lisa keith
jolly describe keith's performance
tonight
i thought in the beginning keith had a
lot of uh good energy i do have to say
when [ __ ] hits the fan she kind of
disappeared
keith please that stuff that should not
happen
oh god
keith you've got to understand it's your
business
never ever feel agitated nervous about
working inside your business
[Music]
it's gonna be a big change tomorrow
we're gonna relaunch this restaurant but
lisa and keith
relaunch yourselves
and if you're not going to do that
then [ __ ] close that door
it may have been a rough dinner service
look all those tickets
this is crazy but the new commitment of
lisa and keith oh you're doing such a
nice job lisa it was just enough to
convince chef ramsay to go ahead with
his plan of giving tavellini a much
needed makeover
good morning good morning sorry how's
everybody feeling
nervous look at this my hand is shaking
okay today
we relaunch
your restaurants on the count of three
one
are you crying lee i'm already crying
[Music]
and
three
wow
[Applause]
it's really gorgeous
[Music]
oh my lord mother
elegant
it really is emotional gordon's brought
some energy back to a place that was
really really lacking we've warmed up
the dining rooms with a nice fresh
champagne
wonderful color it's really gorgeous a
textured art wall
stunning
look at your tables
new plates
without any chips in there they're
beautiful beautiful huh oh
come on fine
what do you think it's a new restaurant
it's gorgeous it's the complete makeover
as it's the home run
thank
okay there's more i want to come through
to the kitchen now come in
right look at the space
oh my god this kitchen looks huge
come in there's more space down here as
well come in michael
come here come here come in come here a
proper kitchen that's been decluttered
oh my god i didn't think we could do
this in here
michael how does it feel it feels
amazing sure yeah yeah it really does i
look forward to working in there it's
gonna be a breath of fresh air okay come
outside one more thing
there you go
oh my god
cavolini
family style dining
oh my god a complete new identity very
very happy
it was so refreshing and so new and so
different so excited that you just
really want to just get to work and show
it off to everybody that's your family
up there family style dining yes exactly
right
come in welcome
tavellini's new exciting menu entrees
herb roasted chicken
roasted with lemon thyme and garlic
branzino according to a sort of striped
sea bass beautifully pan roasted so with
fennel and lemon you're a real classic
italian a stunning ozobucco ville demi
glass and gremolata
so delicious
everything is available family style
and a la carte i want to sit down and
have dinner here
get some forks and start tasting
that sauce
oh my goodness i love it oh my god this
is going to be such a talk of the town
people are definitely going to want to
come here and eat because the food is
just amazing
[Music]
with cafe tabelini ready for relaunch hi
welcome
your server will explain the new menu to
you and chef ramsay's new menu in place
an individual portion or a family
portion so you can you can get a couple
of different things yeah it's really
cool it's time for keith and lisa to
show that they are capable of leading
and managing their restaurant hi folks
hi welcome to delaney how are you good
i'll be bopping around tonight making
sure everything's fine
thank you for coming in tonight i need
to give my all to try to make this
restaurant a success but i'm just
nervous as [ __ ]
branzino is uh the roasted fun i don't
know whatever
um
i don't know what that is
look at that what are you doing with
branzino yeah
actually it's a uh this is similar to
it's a fish dish
tail on head off and it's a little
similar to a um
it's a white fish yes very good yes
michael we got a tuscan soup cauliflower
mushroom polenta excellent these first
eight nine tables are crucial yes yes
talk together yes
it's a half hour into dinner service
table six in the window and the kitchen
led by michael is humming for this table
right now i just need a crostini and a
calamari nice nice nice lovely enjoy
very yummy
and it appears as though everyone is
loving the new tavellini experience it's
really really exciting
i'm glad you're excited my heart is not
stopped okay good
let's keep it that way half an hour
service keep it going yes everything's
going really really well it reminded me
of five years ago when we first opened
and we had this vibe and i always wanted
to be here when it was busy hey what's
the overall consensus are they happy are
they enjoying it so far it's so good
that's very tasty
it's now an hour into service and
tabelini's new appetizers are a hit
but back in the kitchen i got two tuscan
beans coming for you as well with the
two muscles danny what two muscles the
smooth running machine has now hit a
major speed bump you're plating two
muscles right now and the dinner service
is about to crumble
michael was this my calamari right is
that right is this lisa's table dan no
this is van's table coming i don't know
see this i'm getting a little awesome
yeah you guys tell me what you give me
what tape mike you got tickets over
there too talk to michael what's coming
next i'm a little [ __ ] up with the
tickets for some reason there's another
disaster in the kitchen it's a big
cluster [ __ ] here now nobody knows
what's going on anymore there's so much
[ __ ] is it not even funny mushrooms
please where's my mushroom polenta
mushroom palette is coming right now
we've been waiting how long an hour and
a half
it's
[Music]
we're using this right here i know how
to [ __ ] cook it but how long just
hold on one second come on that's wasted
the kitchen is just a whole mess michael
what michael what five's meal have they
gotten anything yet no
it's like the worst [ __ ] thing
you could ever ask for come on man
[Music]
it's two hours into dinner service and
the confusion in the kitchen it's so
much [ __ ] is it not even funny is
putting a successful relaunch in
jeopardy i'm a little [ __ ] up with the
tickets for some reason
and chef ramsay knows that there is no
better time than now for these formerly
passive owners to step up keith yes sir
you know this is not right all right
without a doubt get it together please
absolutely yes come on
chef ramsay lit a fire under my butt
keith i need you now to pull this back i
realized that i needed to get my hands
dirty to make this thing a success so
what what should we do now we gotta
persevere guys gotta persevere keep get
behind the line and get them together
okay what we gotta do is try to work
together as a team it's gonna take a
minute but we have to focus here yes sir
all right baby let's do this look we're
going with lisa's table then we go with
van with keith and lisa now actively
supporting their team
the kitchen somehow manages to recover
table 10 is what i'm picking up calamari
and the roasted chicken right that's it
here michael thanks pal
and pushes out the remainder of the
dishes this is table 15 for lisa
to very content customers
that is absolutely
amazing that's it that's done that's
going perfect bro we're beautiful guys
i'm really really proud of you you guys
are a really amazing team thank you boss
if we can have tavamini be successful
like tonight i think everything will
will work itself out and our marriage
will have a chance to be successful too
have a great night everything was
wonderful i appreciate that it makes my
night thank you
okay
tonight
we were teetering on disaster
but it's not how you start it's how you
finish your
lisa
and keith you
did a bloody good job
well done
you all did a good job thank you i think
we have a lot of work still ahead of us
um i think tonight was just a stepping
stone absolutely right lisa
keith you've been given a second chance
this restaurant needs you not just the
dining room but the kitchen yes
absolutely keith
loud and clear chef loud and clear
i think that gordon's motivation brought
some positive energy back to a place
that was really really lacking anything
positive lisa i can't do any more
i come back and that front door is
boarded up i'm going to be so upset
it won't be look after your family
keep it going
take care
it is a little scary that gordon is
leaving you know we have a long way
ahead of us now and we have to really
you know just get to work can you stop
okay
thank you for helping us
keep it going we have such a foundation
to work from but with our family
problems with the restaurant issues all
in one it needs to start from the bottom
up and i think we need to start from a
clean slate to uh you know be successful
[Music]
unbelievable i'm actually shocked that
this has ended on a positive note and
who would have thought that her family
being ripped apart
has been saved by family style dining
that's exactly what happened
here at tavellini
finally
a taste of italy
that's it
in the weeks that followed yo you find
it a little funny that they're outside
arguing right now
keith and lisa struggled with their new
roles as leaders it's too much for me
and didn't commit to the restaurant the
way chef ramsay had hoped i need to have
a my cigar
in addition a rocky marriage that was
moving in the right direction is now
over what is going on here do me a favor
cause i would advise you to zip it up
keith and lisa have separated
and the future of tabelini is uncertain
the doors are now closed and one wonders
if they will ever open again